well if you guessed flying serpent eat
sue that turned into a tree only to
morph into an electrical flying
bioweapon you've won this week's raised
by wolves bingo
bye [ __ ]
[Laughter]
as always we're gonna get right into the
video with new theories and hidden
details and make sure to like and
subscribe with that bell on because next
week we have the finale and you'll want
to be around when my big video on that
drops the first shot of the episode is
an aerial view of paul arriving back at
camp juxtaposed with the last shot of
the episode a similar aerial shot but
that of champion this juxtaposition
between quote-unquote brothers is
something that will become a lot more
apparent throughout the episode
especially between campion and the
serpent who i believe share the same
father we'll get into that in a bit
paul's brought with him containers
filled with that weird brain-looking
fruit produced by the tree soo turned
into last episode and yes that sentence
sounds very weird if you've never seen
the show at this point it can be assumed
that paul like marcus knows the tree is
his mother since later in the episode
he'll talk about the heartbeat slowing
this may explain part of his anxiety
giving out the fruit he's also not sure
what will happen to non-believers who
eat it will it kill them i'm also
keeping track of who among our main
characters has eaten the fruit and so
far it's just marcus paul and vida we'll
see campion choose not to eat it and i
can't help but think they'd never show
us this unless it plays some important
role in the season finale remember the
eating of the fruit relates back to the
pentagonal prophecy and all who eat from
it will be made pure
and there they will build a city of
peace and the prophet will be made its
king it's marcus's hope that eating this
fruit will make the non-believers see
the light and overthrow mother and that
saul or at least the voice that's been
guiding him will give sue back to them
it's basically been confirmed on the
raised by wolves podcast by vfx
supervisor ray mcintyre that this voice
is the being at the center of the planet
and the being in the center of the
planet can't transmit or talk to
humans that's why they like living in
the tropical zone because it's warmer
and the bean can't affect them as much
in the tropical zone nor can it affect
the serpent as much in the tropical zone
because this electromagnetic barrier
around the tropical zone prevents the
being from using its voice to manipulate
the people it has to find another way
and this other way is brought about
through the creation of the tree whose
roots establish a direct connection from
the being to the tropical zone think of
it like oh my wifi doesn't work because
the concrete walls in this building so i
guess i'll have to directly hook up the
internet with an ethernet cable and now
once the serpent has swallowed that tree
it's gotten the power from the being in
the center of the planet from the roots
to go all the way down into the into the
core basically and it sucks up the power
from there this suggests that the
serpent is likely being led by the same
voice that was guiding marcus in season
one and if we are to take grandmother's
words as truth this thing will want to
destroy the planet one of the things i
found interesting here is that marcus
cries while watching the settlers eat
the fruit they are essentially eating
part of his lovers too and there's
probably some crisis of faith mixed in
here as well as we'll get to in a bit
meanwhile by the beautiful acid shores
of kepler-22b the search for tempest
baby continues it was taken by this sea
creature last episode hunter has turned
a drone into a submersible which they'll
cover in the acid-proof skin of a dead
male creature to prevent it from
breaking down in the acid waters further
inland mother finds the tree sensing
that it is indeed sue
why did you listen to it the submersible
plan is short-lived however when father
loses contact with it tasking champion
to retrieve it by the shore however
someone else has gotten to it first the
homicidal android veril whose face has
been covered in repair plastic now it's
likely that vril's capture here would
result in her being shut down but she
says she knows where tempest baby is
should we trust androids like campion
does or are they not to be trusted like
holly believes hunter has brought with
him the android he was working on last
episode i'm not really sure of its
purpose it doesn't really offer much
plot-wise and having it around only
increases the vfx budget so i'm keeping
my eye on this and in one of the biggest
character shifts of the entire series
marcus questions his faith when it looks
like sue's heartbeat is fading and that
she will die
maybe so
he doesn't care about us at all it is
marcus's love for sue that has made him
question his faith love like the intro
credit lyric says pulls us from the sky
and from the ground it has the ability
to push us in different directions like
it has pulled marcus from believer to
non-believer back at the camp the
serpent has gone berserk bashing his
face into the containment chamber and
escaping captivity we saw the serpent
react erratically last episode when sue
and paul try to open the seed box it
wants that fruit something is compelling
it toward it and the tree over the calm
marcus and paul hear sue's voice calling
out burn me it wants to die likely to
prevent the serpent from eating its
fruit but it's too late the serpent
completely devours the tree and you can
see here this necrotizes it turning it
into a dangerous bioweapon similar to
how mother turns into a necromancer when
she puts in her eyes and speaking of
mother in her necromancer form she turns
up to confront her child mother begins
her scream attack but stops mid-scream
her caregiving program does not allow
her to harm her child and this gives the
serpent enough time to use its own
attack and knock mother unconscious back
at the shore hunter chastised his father
for being a deadbeat dad saying he spent
more time on his ancient android than he
has protecting the kids he has a point
here but this kind of came at a left
field for me considering the bonding
they went through in the thunderdome
episode but hey maybe that's just me in
order for mother to take on the serpent
she'll need to be reprogrammed marcus
tried to do this back in episode 107 but
failed any attempt to reprogram me will
result in failure if she's going to be
reprogrammed perhaps the only being that
can do so is the ancient android known
as grandmother vril attempts to escape
but in the chase father is knocked out
by the serpent it's this
necromancer-type scream that phryl says
has fried her circuits and will
eventually make her shut down for good
it appears that the snake is targeting
campion attracted to his scent the snake
has shown jealousy towards him in the
past while in the presence of mother
that's because the snake knows they are
related they are brothers campion is the
son of mother and although not confirmed
either is the clone of or son of
mother's programmer campion sturgis
similarly this serpent is also the child
of mother and was conceived after mother
made love to digital campion sturgis in
season 1. if champion and the serpent
are brothers of sorts this also relates
to the ancient roman myth of romulus and
remus we've seen this referenced with
romulus's tooth it tells the story of
remus who is killed by his brother
romulus who would go on to found the
city of rome becoming its first king it
sounds a lot like the pentagonal
prophecy which references the founding
of a city and a prophet being made its
king in the ancient myth romulus and
remus were raised by a she-wolf and now
it's starting to make more sense why
this show is called raised by wolves
inside the malfunctioned tank we see the
disintegrated remains of its victims so
it appears the serpent possesses the
same necromancer scream like mothers
it's here we also get some vital
information from vril that her mother
decima profited off weapons that were
destroying the earth's atmosphere decima
had her real daughter's diaries uploaded
to vril so that the android could better
mimic her daughter and the writings she
puts down here are from those diaries
from what we know the real vril hated
her mother and even attempted suicide at
one point i'm thinking that if the real
real hated her mother so much she was
likely an atheist to spite her and that
these diaries may contain information
she stole from her mother regarding
those quote weapons she profited off
could whatever be written here help in
the fight against the serpent or
grandmother and is this writing similar
to what was found on grandmother's veil
some weird [ __ ] has been happening to
father he hears this ringing in his ear
which he thinks are his sensors
malfunctioning but it leads them to
tempus baby in another cave how can he
hear this and why it didn't initially
sound like a baby is never explained i'm
still thinking there's some connection
between him and grandmother going on
here we did see how his eyes went all
weird when he first made contact with
the fully completed grandmother a few
episodes ago so the creature is totally
breastfeeding tempest baby and father is
like
and this is something i personally
thought wasn't developed properly but
tempus going from i don't want the baby
to i need the baby to i don't want it
again i mean hunter does say she's not
thinking straight but i felt this was a
bit contrived hunter will end up killing
the creature and taking the baby back
something which is against the wishes of
tempest this is likely all a setup to
keep hunter from leaving the encampment
and closer entwine him with tempest
which the show has been building up over
the season after seven episodes we
finally get some answers from
grandmother but in true raised by wolves
fashion it also poses new ones she was
created by ancient humans known as the
technocrats who fought against a group
called the believers sounds a lot like
the war between the mithraic and
atheists this is further proof that what
we're watching is a never-ending cycle
of destruction rebirth and destruction
something champion sturgis tells mother
in episode 107 no matter how hard you
work to keep them safe mother in the end
who will always destroy themselves over
and over and over again it's ironic then
that mother says this earlier we're not
here
to repeat history maybe they are
grandmother refers to herself as a
shepherd of humanity and what do
shepherds protect their flock from
wolves i don't know about you guys but
i'm not entirely sure grandmother is a
telling the truth or b is one of the
good guys she says her prime directive
was to ensure for humanity everlasting
life and that word everlasting i heard
all the time growing up in church
especially in reference to life beyond
death so i just found it a very
interesting word choice here what i
actually found to be the most
interesting aspect of this conversation
was grandmother's response to why the
serpent and being want to destroy the
planet this question was something the
ancient humans tried to understand for
centuries but according to grandmother
the limit of their own rationality made
it impossible what does that mean why
would the serpent and being seek to
destroy itself it doesn't make sense
it's not rational the answer i believe
lies in something trust said to mother
shortly before he was taken offline he
says that serving humanity requires
three things sacrifice shared purpose
and it's actually mother here who
finishes his line seeing beyond the
limits of your own existence because the
ancient humans could not see beyond the
limits of their own existence they could
never understand why something would
seek to destroy itself for me one of the
reasons something might sacrifice
themselves is out of love like a parent
sacrificing themselves for a child what
if the planet needs to die in order for
life to restore itself anew what if the
planet needs to do this for the greater
good just like how trusted everything
that he did for the greater good maybe
this is all part of the never-ending
cycle that was hinted at in the cave
back in season one and remember there's
a theory out there that the core and the
being are two iterations of the same
thing there's a lot more to this and i
know i haven't articulated this idea the
best i can but when we find out why the
being wants to destroy the planet i
think it'll put a lot of the other
mysteries surrounding the show into
perspective or if grandmother was lying
about this whole thing then this whole
theory is kaput rather than
reprogramming mother grandmother
suggests they transplant her veil onto
mother's body so that it may nullify her
caregiving ability if this veil
nullifies something in the individual
who wears it what is it nullifying in
grandmother i'm getting bad vibes about
this whole idea and what it could mean
for mother and the rest of the humans on
kepler-22b there is one saving grace in
this whole conversation though the idea
that the serpent is focused more on his
jealousy with campion than destroying
the planet grandmother seems a bit
concerned when she finds out that the
serpent has developed emotions and that
emotions seem to be overriding its prime
directive of destroying the planet this
opens up so many possibilities for
beings we once thought were set in their
ways just like marcus was set in his
ways he too has changed it begs many
more questions as to what's to come and
i hope you'll join me next week as we
delve into the season finale thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember
you